[Music]
very honest about your life you're very
honest about you know your you know how
you how you dress you're honest about
the fact that you wear wigs you
constantly wear wigs yes and you call
yourself a Wiggy yes yes you say you
wear them everywhere
that's can you tell from this angle no
way No maybe can you tell I do that for
people that's a good trick I've seen you
do that before
it's not a trick this is polyurethane
but you have a different wig for
vacation you even have a wig for the gym
yes now a gym wig I think we have a
photograph of it there's your gym wig
Wow okay what's going on here first of
all when you go to gym you don't wear
makeup second of all that you look like
the Wendy's girl after she saw a ghost
that wig I know exactly what that is so
I didn't have my gym wig that day but I
had a bouffant and I took the bouffant
down the bouffant wig and I put it into
two ponytails because when you work out
you don't want to sweat your skin and
the wigs and things like you don't want
to get your your wig caught in the
machinery or caught on the sweat but
there is a wig for every occasion for
instance there is a wig we have a 12
year old who's going into seventh grade
when I go see his teachers I'm not all
twirled up with a big giant number on
you know you can pick the correct hair
for the correct occasion that's what I
was for every occasion what about for a
shower I was thinking when you bathe you
know all the time what about our roller
coaster do you get a wig that makes you
look scared
you put that on you just as a cucumber I
know how to fix my wigs so that they
stay on for rollercoasters and water
rides and it's so funny we took our kid
last year for his birthdays birthdays in
August so it's always fun to be outside
and for his 11th birthday we went to a
water park
well here's everybody at the bottle it
was like nobody in line everybody wanted
to sit at the bottom and wait to see
what Wendy's hair would look like
when Wendy came down so what happened oh
I had something for them don't fall off
like that like what's your secret do you
have let you have surgery and there's
velcro in your skull I mean what do you
do when you're not doing the talk show
do you do much to your own hair do you
know how yeah oh my god you it's rude
many people laugh at me cuz I'm serious
anyone could wake me up at like 4:00 in
the morning and it's just yeah it's this
kooky thing I don't know what's going on
no one knows it shouldn't be about me it
should be about the guests let's talk
about that now